it's great to welcome to the program
today Sanford Levinson who is a legal
scholar professor at the University of
Texas law school and co-author along
with his wife Cynthia of the book fault
lines in the Constitution the framers
their fights and the flaws that affect
us today a Sanford so great to talk to
you today I'm glad to be here so to
begin with for people who maybe aren't
familiar with the genesis of the
Constitution what was going on in the
United States that prompted the founding
fathers to realize that the Articles of
Confederation were in some way not
working or falling short and that
writing a constitution was something
that made sense
right there are three principal things
first of all the so called national
government I used that term advisedly
was incapable of getting any money what
they could do in effect was to ask the
states to contribute but by 1786 I think
they were contributing something like a
total of six hundred and thirty six
dollars so that's the first thing no
money secondly there were fears of
various military attacks from a variety
of European countries but also from a
variety of Indian tribes many of whom
for very sensible reasons had supported
the British during our secession from
the British Empire um and so there was
real concern about the ability of this
new country to defend itself the third
thing is that there were trade Wars
which is something we're really with
today in an international context but
there was no established notion of free
trade among the various states and there
was some genuine hostility between an
among a number of the states so that
people like Alexander Hamilton and
others described the system under the
artisan Federation is quote imbecilic
unquote and something had to be done
when the transition from the Articles of
Confederation to the Constitution to
place how much discussion do we know how
much discussion there was about writing
the Constitution in such a way to
indefinitely account for however society
might change and the reason I asked that
is that now there is a big debate over
to what degree do we need to be amending
the Constitution on an ongoing basis to
account for how drastically life has
changed today from when it was written
was there much discussion of accounting
for that at the time of its writing a
straight question I think that the most
accurate answer is no that the first
Constitution that is the article
Federation lasted a grand total of six
years I think that if you could have
interviewed the framers they would have
been thrilled to be told that the 1787
Constitution would last 50 years I think
if you said well you know you're really
writing something that should last
forever
I think they would have said you know
that's crazy in part because they were
extremely aware of what they repeatedly
called the lessons of experience and the
need to update government in terms of
those lessons Cynthia and I do not
engage and founder of ashing we think
that the founders by and large were
admirable people trying to respond to
what they thought were the chief
challenges of the day and that they
weren't utopias they were trying to
develop a document that could get us
through the next several years where
several might mean twenty-five or fifty
but they expected amendment and quite
frankly I think a lot of them expected
new conventions article 5 which is the
amendment article explicitly allows for
new conventions and I think that most of
the framers would be astonished to be
told
there's been no national convention
since 1787 where has there been over 230
state constitutional conventions since
1787 so there is the view from some that
it is immensely difficult to amend the
Constitution so my question is sort of a
two-part question the first part is how
do you assess the difficulty of amending
the Constitution in the context of sort
of modern society and number two if
indeed the founders were so welcoming or
expecting of significant amending of the
Constitution as the country changed why
did they set the level of difficulty
that they set right another great
question what they faced in something
eighty-seven was an article
Confederation that required unanimous
consent of the state legislatures of
every state so from their perspective
article 5 which requires quote only
unquote three quarters of the states to
assent to amendment was a big
improvement secondly article 5 worked in
the first let's call it 15 or 20 years
we got the Bill of Rights in 1791 our 12
amendments were sent out ten of them
were ratified we call them today the
Bill of Rights in 1800 or 1801 the
problems to put it mildly of the way we
selected presidents was revealed in the
tie between Thomas Jefferson and Aaron
Burr and we got the twelfth amendment
which changed things for the better
though not enough as far as I'm
concerned and I'm skipping the 11th
amendment which is much more esoteric
but in 1793 the Supreme Court issued a
very controversial decision about states
rights and it was reversed so if you
look at our
early history you could say we know 3/4
is a lot but the system is more or less
working in the modern world 3/4 of 50
where you have the distribution that you
now have of small states and indeed very
small states and not only large states
but very large states and a far far more
polarized country then even was the case
in 1787 it has become functionally close
to impossible to amend the Constitution
so you know political scientists have
looked at that looked at this and some
have said United States National
Constitution is the most difficult to
amend Constitution of the world and one
of the things we talk about in our book
and frankly I think one of the things
that is especially valuable about our
book is that we look not only at the US
Constitution but also at the fact that
every state has its own Constitution
there are 51 constitutions the United
States and if you look at the state
constitutions they are all easier to
amend than the National Constitution so
it's not the case that the American
people are reluctant to amend their
constitutions in fact the typical state
has had close to three different
constitutions over their histories
rather we have a peculiar religious like
veneration of the National Constitution
that makes it almost unthinkable to talk
about amending it but even if you do
think of amending you then come up
against the concrete reality that it's
extraordinary difficult to get
two-thirds of each house of Congress and
then even if you get it it's even more
difficult to get three-quarters of the
states so one of the areas that is of a
lot of interest right now because of the
current administration is the Census and
how should it be carried out what is
really the underlying purpose of the
census from from a sort of
constitutional historian perspective
what was the point of establishing the
census to begin with since is an
extraordinarily interesting part of the
Constitution because you can make an
argument that it's really one of the
very very few things Congress must make
sure is done the other is actually
setting up a Supreme Court of the United
States but for example setting up
circuit courts and district courts
that's optional with Congress it's
optional for Congress to declare war and
not to declare wars etc etc but the
Constitution requires that a census be
held every ten years and the reason is
deceptively simple it's the house
representatives that the house is
allocated more or less proportionately
unlike the US Senate and so if you're
going to have a major branch of Congress
where representation is a function of
the population of the States you have to
know the population of the states it's
really as simple as that
and it's every 10 years because the
framers were smart enough to realize
that the United States was that I name a
country there would be lots of
settlement there would be people moving
around so you couldn't necessarily
depend that the population of Virginia
in 1790 relative to the population of
Tennessee would be the same in 1800 or
1820 etc etc so the Constitution
requires every 10 years without
exception interestingly in my reading
although it requires it it's not clear
what the penalty would be and to whom it
would be assessed if the census does not
happen as scheduled is my reading
correct of that well you know it's one
of those things John Marshall refer to
the Constitution as
great outline and so there are things
that are specified one of them is you
gotta have a census but again the
question you ask is is a very shrewd one
what if the president says you know I
don't think so
then what do you do do you charge the
president with violating the law well
actually this morning is being spent on
the mower hearings and hearing Robert
mower saying over and over again the
Justice Department says you can't indict
it's sitting president
so could you impeach a president for
refusing to take care to enforce one of
the most basic obligations of the
national government which is to conduct
a census I think the answer is yes but I
think it would require a sense of
national outrage led by Congress that
the president is being derelict with
regard to one of his most fundamental
responsibilities which is to make sure
the house representatives is fairly
apportioned yes and in today's hyper
partisan climate it's hard for me to
imagine that there would be that level
of United Miss around that particular
issue but it remains to be seen right I
think you're right we've been speaking
with Sanford Levinson who's a legal
scholar professor at the University of
Texas law school the book co-authored
with his wife Cynthia is fault lines in
the Constitution the framers their
fights and the flaws that affect us
today
Sanford really a pleasure having you on
today my pleasure